thank you
[Music]
all right this is something that
happened in 2019 but there's a
development
um slight development with this and um
you're gonna love it why I think you
will like it too what will I do
who cares just go on
yeah we try not to eat on camera here
I'm not going on camera
this happened to this Dad lead by
example dude in the UK uh his house is
being robbed by two burglars right oh I
like it yeah
you're right you know us well because
I'm picturing I'm picturing you guys are
wet Bandits I'm picturing what he's
gonna do in return yeah right exactly
exactly I didn't know you were so such
an advocate for crying bro burglary
crime on time I gotta speak up for him
yeah so um these two burglars robbing
his house they steal his motorcycle and
they're riding off with it he gets in
his car and he chases them they reach
like a really sharp turn he can't stop
and he crashes into the burglar oh yes
the burglars got on together yeah yeah
that's what I was thinking too he kills
the burglars and now he has to go to
jail he didn't kill him he didn't kill
them the image I need to see they're
like this is just our starter business I
don't know and then the guy get on and
then his buddy gets on once we really
get rolling we'll get a company car so
these two thieves
um even though they have a prior
criminal history of theft reckless
driving shoplifting drug dealing
criminal damage all that across the
board they are sentenced to 200 hours
community service was this California no
the UK oh [__] that's even worse huh all
right so they get sent to 200 hours of
community service the guy who chased him
down and hit him uh just got out of
prison he's been there 22 months oh my
God no [__] way dude he got in
trouble for hitting this it's not it's
not work alive isn't it that's what
they're saying
a bike ain't worth a life isn't it
[Laughter]
what their logic is yeah because did you
live in the UK or something yeah it was
really crazy I know right close to it
are you Welch it's Northern it's
Northern it's different so he uh the
charges causing Serious injury with
dangerous driving that's what he got
charged for oh my God this kind of
reminds me of the Dane Velasquez case it
makes me so sad where like his daughter
um is molested and then so obviously any
dad would be [__] pissed as [__] so
he gets in his car and he has like
reckless driving when it chases him down
and then he ends up getting locked up
for hell along and then but he wasn't
shooting at him
but the other and the other side yeah it
was an empty road and the Molester are
just [__] out and about continuing
their molestation or whatever and it's
like right shouldn't everyone that's
involved in this case just be like yeah
put in the yeah keep it fair if you want
to like solve the case don't have people
that were the original perpetrators
still being able to walk around and the
people that are trying to get Justin
it's almost like the Justice system's
[__] up it's crazy it's because they
try all the cases separately so when you
trial the case two separate ways then
you look at them as two identical I mean
two separate
um independent things so it's like this
one's reckless driving endangerment well
it's all like code based set of like
people based that's why it's so weird
because it's like that's like me sock
and Nick Nick socking me back a second
after those were two cases Bros is not a
one fight yeah this is two cases of
separatism
this is a fight bro I don't know let me
just see this real quick because I put
you in the dick dude you punched my face
I'll punch you in the dick that's true
so this dude um he lost pretty much like
50 caves life savings for his lower fees
sucks so they started to GoFundMe now
that he's out and it's at this point has
reached 150k oh crazy crazy it's kind of
a thing but now the burglars are like oh
let's keep doing this isn't it
[Laughter]
it takes two guys to steal one
motorcycle that's crazy the sucky thing
is that even though you know that's nice
that the GoFundMe is doing well but he
was in there over almost two years last
two years dad by the way so his kid lost
like this time with his dad and what are
those they're just doing community
service the burglars yeah or maybe they
didn't even do it there's done nothing
happens I know right what's 200 hours of
communities like raking leaves that's it
at the London Park they can do other
things too like for my community service
in high school we had to get a certain
amount of hours and I just volunteered
at a cat shelter oh that's what I just
fed kitties and like but is it a
difference for a community service that
is done maybe I was I was sentenced to
community service litter they like pick
up yeah you gotta over here you gotta
[__] be on the side of the freeway
just pick up trash with an orange vest
[__] I said I was sentenced to
it I actually did it why making shut up
what was the crime by the way so
graffiti so it's like you either if you
don't have a set organization like a
non-profit or a church or something that
does community service that you can
volunteer time and do hours for then you
go to the city and you pick up trash or
whatever I think they pick up trash and
stuff but when I was at the church when
I was at the church I was hooked up
because my mom was like can we do his
hours at the church yes you can and then
my pastor signs off on it yeah I just
[__] painted doors oh you had to
actually do work though for a little bit
and then later
and they sentenced you to painting
he tags like painting huh well I'll show
you paint these Church doors it's like a
pit my ride punishment we heard you like
painting so we put you in the church we
put fish in the doors
so we're gonna send to the paint yeah
I said it's YouTube graffiti it just
made me half happy
yours is one of the easiest things I
could ever imagine doing it wasn't even
hard and I barely did an hour work the
other couple of hours I just talked to
this pastor and then bugging he bought
me lunch and [__] dude that's the key
you got free lunch that's the key dude
no that's what most community service
ends up being like when I had to do the
same thing for graffiti at age
graffiti yeah
[Laughter]
what are you gonna do what was your tag
name I used to write shame s-h-a-m-e oh
you're ahead of your time but that it
wasn't because I thought it was cool
those were the letters I could do the
best yeah yeah was it the stucius no
representing for anything nothing
Christianity I like the idea that you're
somewhere I like the idea that you're
somewhere and you see a blank wall and
you're like [__] I gotta represent but I
tagged it I picked the dumbest places to
tag like pick up sticks or a [__]
bands Chinese race yes but I would tag
in like places that would be a [__] to
clean attack on the ceiling
and like uh I imagine someone was just
with a sponge just [__] this kid so my
friend's brother and his like friends
they all tagged but like obviously we
didn't yeah we still liked the art style
so we would do it in like notebooks and
I used to do tricks t-r-i-x
and I that was the same thing it was
like because I liked writing those
letters you just you kind of do your
fonts and you're like yeah man I [__]
said that I was like some cool [__]
cereal as your tag with a bunny and
stuff oh okay I had a cat that was high
he had like cute I had to make the cats
cats the blood and I thought it was hard
the cat's name was ruderalis because
that's a a strain of cannabis and uh his
his caller said Rudy on it oh yeah I did
some backstory to my [__] dog for
Nolan bro origin story and [__] he's a
stoner so his name is ruderalis because
that's the Cannabis and my autism just
went off and I had no one no one
diagnosed me it starts with aesthetic
like I like the letters and then you
have to create a meaning behind it it's
not meaning first it's like that's
pretty all right now what yeah now what
the funny thing is when you get so when
you get in trouble for graffiti what
they do is they they go oh you're the
one that like this is [__]
embarrassing but they're like oh so
you're the guy that run that's right in
shame everywhere huh and then they pull
up these files of all the times that
someone reported graffiti and they're
like what it is so they showed me all a
[__] ton of people right Shameless
yeah yeah and he's like he's like you've
been hitting the city for quite some
time
and I'm like I don't even say shame on
you did they say that please
they look at you they're like he's in
it's not him
let him go we got the wrong guy but the
dude was like he was like really like
mean but funny and he was like he goes
we got we got more than like 50 on file
he goes but those ones actually look
pretty cool so it can't be used
[__] detector they did the S way
sicker than yours yeah bro I make you
not want to do it again stick to H's
you just go paint a door or something I
don't care my community service was like
I got to get my dad to sign off and I
got to do work at the hospital like um
and yeah you had to trade out bed pans
that's worse no I just had to like move
filing straight to bed
I would just move papers from here and
then back the system's so [__] dumb
it is so you can only imagine what kind
of like people are just scamming
Community Services the motorcyclist has
got to paint doors and papers
and he goes yeah 22 months without his
kids for rescuing his own bike yeah and
and he totaled his own bike by the way
that's like the people who like shoot a
guy who is robbing their house and then
the guy has to go to jail because he
shot a guy who's robbing his house and
defending yeah or the guy that's robbing
the house and he hurts himself yeah
exactly the phone through the Skylight
he's like I hurt my back you [__]
[__]
[Music]